paul in doha laufen ja die strategischen
fäden zusammen du hast kontakt von dort
aus nach afghanistan
was gibt es neues zu berichten was ist
am tag danach anders
die stadt liegt immer noch unter schock
kann man sagen heute früh am morgen habe
ich mit menschen in kabul telefonieren
können sie haben mir gesagt dass keiner
weiß was jetzt hier passiert sie haben
auch über die rede von joe biden
gesprochen einer erzählte mir dass
erinnerte ihn daran wie nach nine eleven
gesprochen wurde wir werden ihn jagen
und über die terroristen gesprochen
wurde die das angerichtet haben also
viele fragen sich dort was sind die
konsequenzen der usa jetzt was wir joe
biden was wird das us militär tun das
ist das eine und das andere ist thomas
wenn man sich anschaut wie mittlerweile
wieder tausende von dem flughafen sind
obwohl es einen anschlag gegeben hat
obwohl es so viele tote gegeben hat
daran erkennt man die verzweiflung bei
den menschen in afghanistan
die obwohl dort eine solche erhöhte
gefahr ist und weitere anschläge
passieren könnten erneut vor den
flughafen pilgern und erneut versuchen
in den gesicherten teil zu kommen um
dort raus zu gehen um dort rauszufliegen
paul alle hatten angst vor einem
anschlag der taliban jetzt haben aber
dieses selbstmordattentäter diesen
anschlag verübt dieses und taliban das
muss man wissen auch sie sind verfeindet
wie passt das alles zusammen wie muss
man das verstehen
das ist es und die taliban gegeneinander
gekämpft haben das war in afghanistan
schon immer klar es gab auch vereinzelt
anschläge in kabul in den vergangenen
wochen und monaten
das wurde bei uns im westen nie so
wirklich wahrgenommen landesweit eine
splittergruppe man hat sie so ein
bisschen zusammengetan mit den taliban
mit dem was dort passiert in wahrheit
aber sind das zwei konkurrierende
konkurrierende terrororganisationen auf
der einen seite jetzt die taliban die so
ein bisschen zu tun wollen als würden
sie ja einen stab jetzt machen wollen
sie tun so als wären sie auch bereit auf
bestimmte dinge einzugehen wir deutsche
verhandeln mit ihnen hier unter anderem
in doha wo ich stehe und man hat ihnen
gesagt okay ihr bekommt weiter geld wenn
wir dafür leute rausholen können also
das ist das eine und auf der anderen
seite steht der asc theis ist und die
wollen keine verhandlungen sie wollen
weiter terror sie wollen insbesondere
jetzt zeigen dass es sie gibt und das
haben sie mit dem anschlag bei dem so
viele us-soldaten ums leben kam unter
beweis gestellt und jetzt ist die frage
was passiert als nächstes werden taliban
und a/s gegeneinander kämpfen werden die
amerikaner möglicherweise
ausschließlich gegen diese als
terroristen kämpfen oder was passiert
dort und das ist die frage die sich
heute am morgen danach alle stellen weil
du hast gesagt ist versammeln sich trotz
der gefahr schon wieder menschen vor dem
flughafen was hast du aus den
nachrichtendiensten gibt es erneut
hinweise darauf dass es zu weiteren
anschlägen kommen kann
wir hören dass es eine erhöhte
terrorgefahr weiterhin gibt dass man
davon ausgeht dass es weiter versuche
gibt dort terror anschläge durchzuführen
die die a s hat dort schläfer gehabt in
der millionenstadt es gab davor auch
bereits anschläge das ist nicht der
erste
und warum jetzt warum versucht man das
insbesondere in diesen tagen natürlich
ist der internationale fokus auf diesem
flughafen und gleichzeitig stehen die
us-soldaten in so einem direkten kontakt
immer dort sie sind dabei wenn einen
flüchtlingen den flughafen in den
gesicherten teil verlassen will dann
muss er mit einem soldaten sprechen dann
müssen us soldat in einem direkten
kontakt stehen zu flüchtlingen die sie
nicht kennen und das bedeutet eine
gefahr wie sie die amerikaner in den
vergangenen monaten in den vergangenen
jahren nicht erlebt haben denn da konnte
man sich zumindest ein bisschen
entfernen von der direkten gefahr wenn
es nicht im battlefield war das eine
andere sache ist also nicht im kampf
aber hier ist es ja sozusagen eine
situation an einer mauer oder an us
soldaten direkt mit flüchtlingen
sprechen und dadurch ist die
anschlagsgefahr so hoch ich glaube dass
deswegen auch nicht mehr so viele
menschen aus afghanistan ausgeflogen
werden wie die usa ursprünglich wollten
während du gerade gesprochen hast haben
wir diese bilder gesehen eben vom
flughafen kabul heute morgen wohl schon
wieder
video schildert zehntausende menschen
sich versammeln also wenige meter
entfernt von da wo gestern diese
tödliche sprengladung explodiert sind
stehen wieder so viele und hoffen
irgendwie auf dem flughafen zu kommen
aber noch einmal rückblickend zu gestern
nachmittag mit ein bisschen abstand
findest du denkst du dass diese zwölf
toten us marines und diese 50 60 toten
afghanischen zivilisten sind das auch
die toten von joe biden
natürlich ist der commander am ende er
entscheidet was dort passiert er trifft
die entscheidung am ende geht es immer
um den us präsidenten man muss sagen joe
biden hätte früher evakuieren müssen er
hätte früher auf dienst gehören müssen
und ich glaube das ist ein märchen das
verbreitet wird von der us regierung
dass die dass die us-dienste alles
falsch vorausgesagt haben also die haben
die die gefahren auch in den vergangenen
monaten jahren immer benannt und vor
allem wussten sie sehr genau wie schnell
die taliban vorgerückt sind dh was hätte
die beiden tun müssen er hätte aus
meiner sicht ohnehin dort bleiben müssen
in teilen wir sehen ja was passiert aber
auch nach der tat nach dem angekündigten
rückzug hätte er sagen müssen okay wir
wir machen es nicht so dass wir jetzt
panisch abbauen so zu sagen sondern wir
machen das geordnet ist davon durfte
nicht passieren dass die waffen bei den
taliban geblieben sind alle diese dinge
und das sind glaube ich fehler und die
auf so bayerns kappe gehen und dann was
die toten angeht am ende natürlich auch
auf der anderen seite wie ich gerade
schon gesagt habe die situation dort am
flughafen die evakuierungsaktion egal
wann sie stattgefunden hätte ist
besonders besonders gefährlich weil es
diesen direkten kontakt gibt allerdings
muss man die frage stellen ob es denn
richtig ist dass die usa nur noch einen
flughafen dort zur verfügung haben um zu
evakuieren warum hat man zum beispiel
nicht versucht den flughafen bagdad
zurückzuerobern von den taliban also
warum hat man sich nicht nach
alternativen bemüht paul nun hat
us-präsident beiden gestern die aussage
zurückgenommen dass man den 36 stunden
raus sein wolle aus afghanistan und
gleichzeitig angekündigt dass alle
10.000 ungefähr amerikaner die noch da
sind aus dem land geholt werden würden
wie soll das überhaupt funktioniert
das ist eine frage die sich auch in
kabul alle stellen denn wir haben die
bilder gesehen der weg zum flughafen es
sind wieder tausende dort und am ende
bedeutet dass wieder eine genauso große
anschlagsgefahr wie sie gestern erlebt
haben die jahr angekündigt war von den
diensten fast exakt genau zu dem
zeitpunkt als es dann auch passiert ist
also eine schaurige prognose die genauso
in wahrheit gekommen ist wenn wir jetzt
sehen dass joe biden sagt er das gilt
nicht mehr sozusagen der abzugstermin
oder zumindest in der schnelligkeit dann
hat es damit zu tun was er in seiner
rede gesagt hat dass man rache nehmen
will dass man diejenigen finden wir die
verantwortlich dafür sind das so viele
us soldaten gestorben sind denn ich
glaube wenn er jetzt einfach raus reden
würde das würde das amerikanische volk
ihm übelnehmen man will jetzt erst
vergeltung
[Musik]